so she just fell out of the driver's
seat she just the door opened and she
just fell out and was like a and she was
it was crazy like it was kind of
wild it was so
[Music]
wild welcome back to another fantastic
episode of the careful boys today in the
building we have just michaa AK Michael
and of course we have our resident
[__] Bros Bart I'm not a bro you're
kind of a bro I'm not a bro dude and
then we have our resident hot white
girls Joe and hot white girls yes there
it is okay today we are going to talk
about what was the closest you ever came
to dying
oh what kind of dying yeah uh what are
the different types yeah well so I had
one where it's like car crash there's
like
overdose there's like the class was so
boring
those are the worst oh man he's like of
laughter you look at the clock and
you're like [__] 5 minutes and then you
go back and you're like it's still 5
minutes what the [__] I think we want to
know all those stories but start with
the classroom first yeah definitely
class that's funny I just remember I had
this teacher named Dr Higgins in at
marele already a bom and I remember I
had her she has the most modone low
energy voice [__] and it was right
after lunch
lunch that's the worst and what' you eat
what did you eat like six pizzas no it
was a remember those
tasket oh yeah they started busting out
with sushi in our high school but it was
like imagine like a tuna sandwich you
get mayo and tuna and they just slapped
that inside rice and they rolled it and
they rolled it up into a sushi as a kid
that sounds kind of dang it was actually
pretty bomb and then uh that was the one
of the classrooms where the AC didn't
work too I don't know why so it's like
all hot and and you were running around
at lunch smell like tuna dude and you're
like going raving at night so like
you're sleeping at 5:00 a.m. that's less
relatable to people but yes and then so
I remember like in the class I'm like
cuz every year I promis myself I'm going
to do better so freshman year I promise
I'm going to do better I [__] up
sophomore junior whatever and then so
senior I had her I was like all right
this is the last chance to stop being a
[__] up you're going to graduate and be
good and I remember like okay pay
attention pay attention pay attention
pay
[Laughter]
he almost died just falling over died
and then I did that so much that she
sent me to the hospital I mean not the
hospital to the counselor the ambulance
came to the counselor and she wrote me
up saying like I don't know uh what kind
of like drugs this kid must be taking
but he's not paying attention in class
at all she specifically said drugs drugs
she went straight there then they ask
you and Baro was like oh it's like
ecstasy I Rave a lot but I was also like
he's in there with a pacifier his mouth
still no but I was like that's [__] up
you assume that even though it's true
but that's [__] up you he must be
doing this for a long time Miss Higgins
Dr like this like I relate to that so
heavy man I had like this like the same
monotone teacher but it was a history
class we would come in he would always
put something on the projector and just
read the textbook the room all dark yeah
and it was after lunch in the most
monotone way and all we did every single
day in that class was just take notes on
the thing that he was reading that's it
and then test notes test I would ditch
that class all the time and I think that
teacher didn't care at all he ended up
just passing everybody I never showed up
to that class I you know you know what's
funny I looked forward to those classes
after lunch knowing that the teacher
didn't really care CU that was for sure
nap time that was just straight nap time
but some teachers don't let you nap
that's [__] up yeah this particular
teacher didn't care is also AP Euro
history and I was sitting there was fat
ass textbook same thing projector and
[__] but this is like the time they had
just [__] invented those hoodies that
have like the little slit for your
earphones but the thing is we didn't
have ear earphon with it was like
headphones you remember the so you put
it back here so you had this big ass
thing you had to put it over but the the
cable could go through you thought you
were slick as [__] yeah and you just
sitting there like
this it was like [__] huge but
honestly that [__] was sick I knew for a
fact that even if I were to show up to
that class and even try I was going to
fail because I hated that class so much
that I was not going to apply myself so
I'm like screw this [__] I'm going to
have a longer lunch yeah that's tight I
miss being rebellious but then now if
I'm rebellious there's
consequences yeah that was the one time
I really didn't have that many
consequences who do you have to rebel
against what do you want to do what's
rebellious to you like I'm supposed to
do my homework and I didn't and then
like the teacher's like you didn't do
your homework and I'm like I no I
didn't wait was it said just like that
too and then you're like yeah did
something bad but then like but then
you're I'm an adult and I'm like well if
I didn't do my homework I just cheated
myself cuz I didn't learn this [__] and
then I can't be better and competitive
so I'm like yeah I [__] up you could
just not pay your credit card for 3
months and watch your credit score go
but there's consequences I'm saying
there's consequences consequen I just
want to like [__] Stick it to them
but then like no quences you know cuz
you're the him now I know I became the
man why Jalia let's rebel against Joe
yeah that's that's Rebel that's the
stuff that I actually try to break down
with taica cuz like in the beginning of
his school career even though he only
had two years so far he would [__] up
quite a bit he's actually a pretty good
kid in school now and then I would tell
him like um he' like oh can I mess up
again I'm like honestly I was like you
probably mess up quite a bit at
elementary school like I try to be real
with them but I was like when you're an
adult you can't like I'm like if you go
to college and you like [__] around you
say the f word or whatever the professor
would just pull you out and then if you
after you graduate if you [__] around
with the police officer you just be in
jail are you like dude if you say the f
word like you can't [__] around Tao like
you are you just dropping the F bombs
like consistently but I tell him in
elementary school I'm honestly he's like
what happened if I get kicked out of
school what going to happen I'm like
honestly I just probably find another
Elementary School for you and we try to
help you not get kicked out again but
but as you get old you can't be [__]
around too much man do you ever tell him
that he's going to be a pain in your ass
if he does that no I don't try to put it
on me I try to just like it's my my duty
to help raise you in the right way so
I'm trying my best and then you see like
Brees him yeah he's like okay I'll try
better that's cute and he's good now
that was really cute isn't this show
amazing you come out here it's like the
prp's like dude what the closest you
ever come to
Dy like Father lessons you know what I
mean about not fing up you don't even
expect it when did you when did you
almost die say I would say I almost died
but I had I had a traumatic incident
when I was nine it was a boating
incident and it was a we're fishing I
think it's called trolling when you like
the boat keeps moving right so I was in
the Back 9 years old I was spraying um a
barracuda it was on the floor of the uh
the boat the lid was open but you know
baruda at n yeah so it was like it was
for bait it was for bait how big is a
barracuda it was like this big maybe
maybe this big
so was like this yeah so the whole
opening on the floor was open and the
lid was open right you know how usually
like the car door or the the the trunk
of your not the front the front trunk
whatever the hood the hood yeah uh
usually has like a thing for cars to
hold up those was nothing on this lid
yeah so mind you I'm spraying this cuz
I'm I'm I'm a freaking kid I'm just like
spraying it cuz I'm bored with the hose
yeah with the hose right he's spraying
of fish fish it was dead I was like
maybe I can bring it back to life you
know the waves hit the boat cuz we're
obviously moving it slams down onto my
pinky toe ow and it breaks I actually
have a picture of it too I breaks open
and I go to the hospital get surgery to
stitch back on a month later it's pitch
black so I had to get a surgery to take
it off so now I have nine toes oh tight
so they tried to sew it on but it died
show your toes yo that could have been a
good dance movie it's like you'll never
dance again and you're like danc I was I
was your pinky toe yeah because it's for
balance right so so you're like a Yakuza
but for your toe pinky toes your thumb
toe that's the real balance one I
thought I thought I think they're all
pretty important holy [__] this going be
epic that's insane dude
oh put your feet up to the camera put
your feet up to the camera holy [__]
he's like AI hey Mike don't take this
the wrong way but you got some nice feet
really I'm I'm trying to work on it man
but if you took it the how would you
feel how some how some [__] up do that
BR no like pedicur yeah cuz it was it
was you know dancer feet do you get like
a discount if you go to the pedicure no
but they always do this you know how
they like file your toes they keep going
they like
oh it's not
there no they don't say it to him they
go like this
he immediately talk [__] Bro the smile
gets me dude where they look
damn yeah if you go to a public Spa in
Japan they'll be like oh [__] this guy's
a thug dude he [__] up but he didn't
do his hand that's why he's tatted up
and he's got a missing toe they're like
you can't go to a public Spa in Japan
because uh you have tats so it's
associated with the Yakuza out there you
can't go to an on I can't even go and I
only got even even a lot of gyms you got
to cover up your tats if you want to
work out you can't you got to go like
outside yeah in Japan you got to go like
outside of the main city you could you
have to be super covered up if you're
covered up and they can't tell you have
tattoos you can it's like being a blood
or a [__] right and you're wearing blue
all [__] day and then you're just
telling everybody I'm ready to fight and
it like that's literally what old school
tattoo exposures meant like if you're
exposed that means like oh [__] this
guy's Ready for War right now you could
live in Japan you just can't go to the
public on sense oh okay yeah yeah yeah
no and then now there's hell of people
with tattoos
where like I can't even go sh no you
toally go okay cool you just can't go to
the public stuff like that oh that's
okay yeah you got to go czy yeah there
are some places that allow it it has to
specifically say like and you got to be
outside the the main
city so when did you die n did you
almost die the closest I've almost died
was when we were on like a family trip
we're going to the mountains and it was
a
snowing and which mountains I don't know
where it might have been Angel's Crest
but it kind of happened out of a [__]
movie I remember I was in a back seat I
was destroying a bag of cheex mix cuz I
remember this you don't forget things
like that no and I was [__] you
almost choked on a check mix no no no no
not that like that that's that's kind of
some [__] [__] I think um cuz you just
wait a couple seconds it'll dissolve it
disolve yeah right away especially if
it's a pretzel yeah you fine um but I
was picking out the check and let me
tell you about cheex mix dude can I tell
you about Che what if I just started
talking about check
mix so the the van my dad was driving he
hit like a like black ice or something
oh no and then we literally spun out and
we got to the the railing like at the
edge of the the the road and there
should have been a railing there but
there wasn't and I remember I was on the
left side and I remember looking over
the window like right when we stopped
and I could see straight down the
[__] mountain and it was like it was
out of a [__] movie and I just
remember being like and everybody was
freaking out in the car and they were
like Nick are you okay and I was like
I'm fine it's fine it's not that big
nobody move yeah yeah but it was like it
was it was one of those things where it
literally spun out and my dad turned at
the right time so we didn't [__] fall
off a mountain and it was like I
remember everyone cuz I think it was
like a like a there was like crossing
guards there they were trying to direct
people through traffic or whatever and
everybody was like they kept coming up
to the car like oh my God are you guys
okay we saw what happened and we're like
we're fine we're not down the [__]
Mountain so yeah we're fine dude but
that was the closest I think how old
were you I was probably like in fourth
grade just destroying check mix day cuz
I can't tell you how bad I was wreck is
that also 9 years old or something like
that is it yeah I think so look at you
9-year-olds oh yeah dude just a bunch of
Mavericks dude living life on the edge
we're like Point Break dude you know
what about you Anthony Lee when's the
last time you almost died talk about it
I thought you you had I thought you had
a story that's why you brought the promp
up I'm all about you guys you never you
never almost died before was it an
erotic ex fixation type of thing you
never almost drowned yeah dude I was in
the six person orgy all dudes right and
I was choking anyways on check Mi um CU
I I have a lot of stories but I don't
want to hog it I also I also had a car
accident situation where um my homie was
driving I was in the back seat and and I
didn't have a seat belt on you know when
you're like younger and you're just like
sitting in the middle just like talking
to your friends like that my two homies
here and then uh he's not paying
attention he runs a red light and we get
T-boned by a truck I think it was a
Tacoma a Truck Yeah Tacomas are really
strong too I like them I have I have two
of them but that [__] was crazy because
of how how quick your brain processes
things that feel like slow motion cuz I
vividly remember the moment of my home
you was driving going oh [__] and then
everything for real goes slowmo cuz I
saw the the truck it was white I see it
like this I remember it hitting I
remember me flying this way I hit my
head and I remember seeing glass like
this it's like the movies I see the
glass and right when I hit my head I
black out and the next thing you know
when I come back there's smoke coming
from the hood and the car is still in
motion cuz he's knocked out and his
foot's still on the pedal he's a big
dude he's like 250 lbs so his foot's
still on the pedal um and so we're still
uh [__] kind of making donuts in the
middle of the intersection with smoke
coming up everywhere and then I see my
homie who's in the passenger seat his
name is Patrick he like finally comes to
as well and then I'm like yo put it in
park put in a park and he throws in the
park right before we hit a light post so
it just stops right there and then
everything finally starts to come back
into like realization of what what's
going on I remember the ambulance coming
did you have a concussion I don't know I
don't think so I just remember blackout
for a second coming back I was the first
one to come back Dam my homie was
driving his eyes were rolled in the back
of his head just [__] for like hella
long and then we slapped him to wake him
up and then he like kicked the door
because it couldn't open so you had to
crawl at the other side and I just
remember the it was a family in the
other truck and it was a mom who had to
get carried out like on a stretcher with
a [__] neck brace and stuff like that
whose fault was it it was my homie's
fault oh cuz he ran the red yeah red I
wasn't wearing a seat belt which is why
I like [__] flew around so you don't
have any body injuries or like spinal no
I was I was you got lucky so
lucky how old are you nine no I'm just
kidding uh I was maybe like 15 or 16
damn damn you did have a you did have
almost that that's almost dying he would
have a story of someone dying next to
him it's crazy to go through that and
not have scratches though dude I had the
same situation actually I remember now
that you told that story we're were in
high school our friend was driving it
was like we're all sitting in the back
seat and one my buddy was sitting on our
lap she made a u-turn and she was parked
on the side she made a u-turn and a car
came and T-Bone her she didn't see the
car the lady that hit us she drove into
the street and then she just fell out
the car I remember sing her fell out the
car and I was the only one that was
conscious in the [__] car like
through the window like so she just fell
out of the driver seat she just [__]
the door opened and she just fell out
and was like a and she was it was crazy
like it was [__] kind of
wild girl I it was so wild cuz I
remember seeing it uh she didn't even
close the door right well it was like at
she just fell out like as soon as she
she parked she just fell out the car um
so she just fell out yeah but she flew
out though kind of she kind of she
opened the door it was like in motion it
was just like anyway um our friend that
was driving she broke her femur oh oh
[__] car hit her like right on the drive
and she was a track star she was [__]
and we were all like I think she had
fulles too yeah yeah the big bone I
think she she broke her I remember
seeing and then the homie got knocked
out like
like she was like asleep like did it
ruin her R running career I think it did
I think she had rides too I think she
was she was going to go to college I I
don't know what happened with that
afterwards but I remember her being kind
of [__] up for a real long you think
she gets sad when she hears the song
She's a runner she's a track star and
she's like I'm not why is that song
always playing
around I'm not that was her favorite
song but I were seeing theie the home
girl DEA she hit her [__] head on the
on the on the Wind and she like went out
and I remember seeing that and I was
like I can't believe I'm the only one
that's fine it was [__] up mine's the
same scenario not as dramatic as both of
those but same thing got hit the guy
totaled my car but he did a hit and run
oh so he left but the there's like got
hit next to like a light shop and the
people at the light shop saw and took
his information got it and the police
found him charged him with a felony oh
[__] that's not a typical Colleen story
wow in a regular clean story he gets
away
for the cleen story yeah the the usual
story is my car is taken
for I got to keep my car I got kind of
[__] up uh yeah did you get money from
it no I didn't get money from it my
insurance covered it my car ended up
being salvaged at least he yeah what do
you think he's up to now I don't know
maybe he's out hey somebody else damn
all of my car accident stories has never
been me driving but I'm in the passenger
seat of someone racing and then it gets
total so and then all of the stories of
my near-death is like pretty
self it's like self- stupidity getting
myself in situations like drowning
because uh I was snorkeling one day and
I was so excited from the fish I forgot
that I was not a fish snorkeling at the
surface and I continue to breathe as I
was diving deeper and deeper and then I
breathe the water and I go that's not
air yeah and then I'm choking underwater
and I'm like son of a [__] and then I'm
climbing and if you ever try to cough
while like in water you just breathe
more water right you get up to the
surface and thank God my buddy had his
paddle board and I swam over there
[__] went over and as soon as I was
able to grab it I can puke it out
[__] puked started to breathe all
this fish started coming up eating all
my puke and all these divers were like
oh my God there's fish they didn't know
I was [__]
vomiting we death vomit dude so all of
these people were around me scuba diving
like looking at fish cuz they were
literally surrounding the the the paddle
board and I'm just like puking my guts
out you know what did you eat before uh
I had a three flight pancake it was so
sick it was like it was like so many
different kind right I love a flight of
cookie butter I swear to God that was
the stupidest like moment P fruit when I
was a kid I was climbing on the side of
a cliff uh near my brother's University
and I couldn't get back down so they had
to like call like support to come get me
cuz I couldn't yeah and then there was
like uh there's all these stupid things
I feel like well like you know in high
school it's like you play stupid games
and um I remember there was a driveby
that happened at the house that I was
going to and if I was like I don't know
like 5 minutes any earlier I would have
been in the front too so like most of my
experiences have always been you're
being stupid dude you're lucky not
because it was like oh no I was just in
the car and a car hit us it was like me
and my buddies well he's he's driving
we're racing in the middle of traffic um
and we're eating in and out while he's
driving and they is because it's kind of
trafficky helicop cars on the road he's
weaving in and out he does uh he's
riding on the what do you call it the
side the shoulder the shoulder to get
ahead and then when he weaves right back
in my buddy that he's racing hits him in
the back and does like a whole police
yeah pivot we we're like spinning all
over with a [__] double double in our
hand not the double it's kind of a cool
commercial and then I thought the car
was about to flip it didn't it just kept
you like donutting and then we stopped
and then there's a big rig that just
stopped and we're just looking straight
into like the trucker and then I was
like damn dude that guy could have ran
us over uh but it's all these stupid ass
I think like
teen moves yeah Wicked I got lucky yeah
I feel like there's so many moments I
just feel lucky like yeah we're we're
alive and uh I probably should have died
yeah
y